good morning everybody and welcome to
AEI my name is Robert doar and I'm so
pleased to have you all here this
morning for this important discussion of
education policy in the United States we
are particularly gratified and happy to
have the Secretary of Education Betsy
DeVos with us
her husband dick counselors the
president Kelly and Conway it's a great
honor to have them all here for this
important discussion of a topic that is
particularly important to AEI and our
education policy team led by Rick Hess
and that malkos and we're also pleased
to have and I like to say that AEI is a
washington-based think tank but we're
not at Washington focused think-tank and
so we have three distinguished leaders
around the country from Tennessee from
Arizona and Pennsylvania and they will
talk about how some of the issues we're
talking about here in Washington affect
the children and parents and schools in
those parts of the country and really
that's what our discussion is all about
how can we make our schools better now a
little bit about just to give a sense of
how I come to this issue and look at it
and why I think it's so important some
of you may know that I spent 20 years in
the social services departments of New
York State in New York City working on
any poverty programs and I was focused
on the various issues with our ways in
which we help people get into work and
get out of poverty and move up
economically personal responsibility
work work supports those things were
important but I always knew that there
was another domain another domain of
activity that was equally important to
our safety net programs maybe more
important than our safety net programs
in helping struggling families move up
and helping their children move up
economically and that was the world of
education and no one has done more it
seems to me in expanding options and
choices and fighting for giving parents
and children the ability to make choices
about their future and escape what I was
what I perceived in the city of New York
and have perceived across the country
failing public schools than the current
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos and
so as I look at this and I think about
this issue and I think about the
proposal that the secretary is going to
talk about today
it seems to me it is about just that how
do we provide options for families and
children so they can make the choices
they need to improve their fortunes in
the future no issue is more important it
seems to me in helping families move up
economically and at AI that's a
principal focus of our work economic
opportunity for all so I'm particularly
glad to have the secretary her husband
dick devos they are great friends of AEI
we welcome you back here we're honored
to have you thank you for being here
thank you well thank you all good
morning and thank you to AEI for hosting
this important forum today Robert thanks
for your hospitality and for your
principled conservative leadership
especially now in your new role it's
always a pleasure to be back here with
so many friends our ideas are advanced
by the work of this institute there are
many who have worked for the cause of
education freedom and for our nation's
students especially Rick and NAT so I'm
looking forward to our conversation
today we're here to talk about education
freedom scholarships let me just say a
few things about our proposal to set the
table before our discussion here's what
it is
a five billion dollar annual federal
income tax credit for voluntary
contributions to 501c3 nonprofit
organizations that provide scholarships
to students the key element of the
proposal is freedom freedom for everyone
involved students families teachers
schools States any and all can choose to
participate or they can elect not to
participate that's what freedom is all
about we know gaining this freedom will
require more work in some states than
others and certainly in that body up the
hill but as more states offer more
options to families demand will rise and
pressure
mount on those who have not yet embraced
the opportunity ultimately freedom
scholarships require only one thing
students and parents must be empowered
to make decisions and choices it should
come as no surprise to anyone in this
room why we've stepped forward with a
bold transformative idea for students
American education isn't working for too
many of them we've known this for more
than 35 years the devastating landmark
report a nation at risk detailed the
dire state of American education and
warned us all and I quote history is not
kind to idlers well if there's any word
to describe to many parts of American
education today its idle you've seen our
nation's report card you know what I
mean two and three of our nation's
eighth graders aren't proficient in any
core subject two-thirds we also know
this the United States ranks 24th and
reading 25th and science and 40th in
math in the world you've heard me talk
about these results before and I don't
take any pleasure in reminding anyone
about them yet there are many who pay
lip service to the sorry state of
affairs in American education but offer
more and more of the same as a solution
more spending more regulation more
government they should they assure us
that this time it will work this time it
will be different yet as it said in
these halls we are being mugged by
reality daily that's why now is the time
to do something different something
better
embrace the thing that makes America
great freedom the freedom to learn the
freedom to grow the freedom to rise the
freedom to pursue happiness on this we
can all agree or at least we should be
able to so I remain dumbfounded that
conservatives who masquerade as
education reformers have criticized this
proposal who would have thought that Ted
Cruz or I of all people would be accused
of trying to grow the federal government
think about that for a minute you all
know me I've fought alongside many of
you for more than 30 years to expand the
freedom of families and diminish the
role of government in our lives I
wouldn't support anything that violates
my principles for hours so here's what
our education freedom scholarships
proposal doesn't do it doesn't grow the
government bureaucracy one tiny bit it
doesn't create a new government office
of school choice it doesn't oppose any
any it doesn't impose any new
requirements on States or on families it
doesn't take a single dollar from public
school students and it doesn't spend a
single dollar of government money and it
doesn't entangle schools with federal
strings or stifling red tape in fact it
can't and that's by design the truth is
our proposal is a highly efficient and
effective way of funding education it
connects the dollars to the students not
the system with no bureaucratic sponge
in between the education freedom
scholarships are the conservative answer
to what ails education in America they
also happen to be the answer that a
super majority of parents particularly
African American and Hispanic parents
are looking for they are the reason
education freedom is on the march from
Florida to Pennsylvania from Illinois to
Arizona and many places in between I've
just come back from a tour across the
Midwest to highlight opportunities
education freedom will provide at every
stop I heard from students families
teachers and local lawmakers about how
education freedom is changing lives
but I also heard the loud voices of
bullies who are threatened by that
freedom now it's their right to
demonstrate and to protest and to say
sick things what worries me though is
the message they're sending to parents
and students big Union bullying is
flat-out unjust it's unfair to the many
students and parents who simply want
better for themselves or their sons or
their daughters I've been blessed to get
to know many many families who have
exercised education freedom many have
low incomes many are black or Hispanic
many are burning the candle at both ends
to make ends meet and help their
children have a better life
they aren't anti public school or for
privatization they couldn't care less
about how a school is legally structured
or how the funds flow they care about
their kids they care about them getting
a great education they care about them
being safe they care about how schools
can help them prepare their children for
successful careers and meaningful lives
on the other hand union bosses don't put
kids first they don't put kids kids
futures first they put themselves first
look no further than West Virginia many
of us remember the first strike which
kept students from learning for two
weeks the second strike is far more
telling there was already in place a
deal for yet another pay raise so why
did union bosses force another strike
because the bill would have also allowed
for up to seven charter schools and
would have created ESA s for a very
small number of families maybe enough to
satisfy or to serve less than one-third
of one percent about a thousand of West
Virginia's three hundred thousand
students
this is clearly anti parent an anti
student education freedom is pro parent
and pro student it's not anti public
school if your school is working for
your child you can stay put one parents
freedom to make a choice doesn't mean
you have to make it doesn't it mean
everyone else has to make the same
choice education freedom isn't about
elevating one type of school over
another it's about trusting parents and
believing in students my mission is to
unleash a new era of innovation in
education to drive unprecedented
achievement it will happen in public and
private schools alike and we should
embrace that our obligation isn't to any
type of school its to students America's
students can lead the world because
America must continue to lead the world
it's time we put them first
and that's exactly what education
freedom scholarships will do thank you
and I am looking forward to our
conversation
[Applause]
Thank You Madame secretary
I was terrific I'm ray cast director of
education policy studies here at AEI we
now have about 35 minutes for
conversation with the secretary and also
we the pleasure of being joined by Kelly
Conway senior counselor to the president
of United States thank you for talking
to us counselor all right
I'm secretary you talked a bit about the
education freedom scholarships but
wonder if first we could go a bit more
into the nitty-gritty so you mentioned
that these complement existing programs
in the States
what are those programs in the states
how does this complement those how does
this all work well thanks again Rick for
the opportunity to be here in Kellyanne
it's so great to see you and be here
with you so states can decide whether or
not they'd want to participate in this
program and there are many states today
that actually have some kind of choice
program most of them have chartered
public charter schools and many of them
have private school choice programs what
this proposal would do is be a booster
to all of those programs it could
augment and and expand existing programs
or we've also encouraged people to think
more broadly about what new creative
ways they could use the funds that would
come from the tax credit program to help
satisfy the need in their state and I
think about rural states in particular
many times people will say well there's
no you know there's no way we're going
to have another building next to a rural
high school but I say well think
differently about what choice can mean
what about students in that school one
of whom might want to study something
that that school can't possibly offer
that school there that child that
student could elect to take that course
virtually from the finest teacher
somewhere in the world or perhaps
there's a handful of students in that
who learn differently but don't have the
opportunity to go somewhere else
physically to school there's no reason
they couldn't opt to have a micro school
within their school that approached
their education they're learning
differently and allow them the right fit
for them there so there's no end to the
ways to be creative to really implement
choices for families and this is meant
to really help jump-start states that
haven't taken that leap out to encourage
them to do that not mandate it and to
augment states that already have taken
that leap and and want to continue to
provide opportunities for students so
counselor and it sounds like we're
talking about more than private school
choice programs are more than charter
schools
I heard the secretary talking about a
variety of options so how does this work
a state say a state already has some of
these programs who decides that they're
there how do they work how does this
money support those programs how does if
Congress enacts this law how does that
change any of this in states let me echo
the gratitude for having us today and
for elevating such an important issue
into the consciousness of the audience
here and anyone who's watching now or in
the future the secretary gave a very
powerful set of opening remarks that I
think touched upon many different
aspects here and I'd like to amplify
some of those after I answer this
particular question so in about 18
states they have programs and they've
obviously opted in these states are not
red or blue politically they're pretty
diverse I mean they're everything from
Florida in Arizona to Illinois as we
said and in those states you have in the
way this would work federally is you
have a scholarship granting organization
and it involves it usually involves
educators education specialists perhaps
others could weigh in but they have to
approve of the formula they have to
approve of who or what whom or what
would receive the actual monies and what
they would do with that but one thing
that comes with the freedom the
secretary has so elegant eloquently
spoken to this morning is flexibility
one of the main points of appeal to me
as a public policy practitioner as
somebody works on behalf of the country
took an oath to the Constitution and as
a parent is the flexibility to use those
monies certainly for the classroom and
for traditional curriculum and
instruction but also for tutoring for
summer programs for virtual learning for
needs of the educators may have
identified in that area and that is
really why even though it's a it's a
it's just it's on your federal tax form
the deduction you would take the credit
you would take it doesn't reduce your
tax liability but it increases the
optionality for these students in these
states and with that freedom comes the
flexibility and I think that's
incredibly important so this does not
disturb the state programs if anything
the state programs are best practices
that show hey this is already working in
places on a state-by-state level and
they've been wildly successful it is
truly that if you build it they will
come and who has come many outfits many
organizations have come because they
figure if they are paying you know taxes
anyway and get a tax credit that
actually helps they can more readily
direct the money toward scholarship
granting opportunities in their own
states and this is something that's been
a priority for this president certainly
the education freedom scholarships but
just the overall flexibility and the
freedom agenda for education I have to
say the very first time I met Cory
Booker before he held public office was
in the education space I met him at a
school choice event in New Jersey or
maybe it was Manhattan I believe it was
near Newark New Jersey and he was
groomsman in a mutual friend of ours in
the school choice movement he was able
to cross the wedding aisle but not the
political aisle now unfortunately and
and that's that really is unfortunate
because as the secretary pointed out she
could she described it as being
dumbfounded it is really disheartening
if not maddening to see a lack of
bipartisan consensus on what is
quintessentially a nonpartisan issue we
should really put the kids first and
echo what we've done legislatively on
measures like criminal justice reform
and I think
more propitiously the drug crisis every
single Democrat who voted for HR six the
most comprehensive piece of legislation
on any single drunk right crisis in our
nation's history a year ago every single
Democrat voted in favor of it so we can
do this when it's as something as
fundamental and nonpartisan in nature as
giving people access to more treatment
and more prevention education when it
comes to drug making sure people who
have paid their debt to society no
longer languishing in prison and in this
case giving these children these these
students more flexibility and freedom to
learn and to prosper and to be
economically independent let's stay with
that for a second counselor you just
mentioned the first-step Act where there
was broad bipartisan support obviously
we have not seen that thus far with
regard to the education freedom
scholarships what's the difference here
why is it playing out so differently in
the one in education than it did in
criminal justice reform you know well
both speak to that and the secretary
certainly touched upon the influence of
the unions and she was remarking that
the union bosses don't put the students
first that is true and I would challenge
and defy each of them to prove otherwise
what are they so afraid of it doesn't
take money away from the public schools
it just amplifies the number of and
actually it helps the public schools in
that as the secretary said maybe that
school already offers courses and
resources that another institutional
learning does not so perhaps they'll
benefit as well from this but I noticed
a lot of many of the folks who are
against who don't put the students first
also don't put their own children in the
public schools and that is a cruel irony
well let's just call it hypocrisy it's
past 9:00 a.m. and it's Tuesday and
Congress doesn't resent us it's ironic
but it's hypocritical as well and so
back to my point where you you have
Elizabeth Warren of all people formerly
talking about the benefit of fully
funded vouchers and all the freedom and
flexibility that would wrought that
could bring that could deliver the
aforementioned cory booker many
Democrats over the years I remember
working with Senator Joe Lieberman and
representative and also pastor Floyd
flake on education reform in a
bipartisan fashion in the Congress 20
years ago and you know the only thing
that has changed the only thing has
changes we have more students in need I
would challenge any of them to say this
isn't pure naked raw politics and that
really is too unfortunate because we
have an entire generation suffering from
the lack of bipartisan support but hope
springs eternal and maybe they will see
that what's happened in their own state
sees 18 states and growing and what
could happen if we just put it to the
test at the federal level and I would
just echo what Kellyanne said every
single president and Secretary of
Education since charter schools became a
thing have supported charter schools in
their expansion and so it is
inconceivable to me that we would now be
in a place where Democrats just resist
and and deny the benefit to students
that freedom can provide and that
opportunity for each to find their right
fit would mean ultimately for our nation
so let's talk a bit about the scope and
proposal there's the figure five billion
dollars attached to it how does that
work is that is the anticipation that
there will be five billion dollars a
year in contributions how would this be
allocated across States so the yes five
billion dollar annual fund that
individuals or corporations would choose
to voluntarily contribute a portion of
their federal tax bill to one of these
501 C 3 organizations so participating
states would name the 501 C 3 s that
could receive them and then if all 50
states participated each state would get
a portion of those funds as designated
by the title to a formulation so a
combination of consideration of poverty
and
halation and and for those if states
chose not to participate those funds
would go then to the the ones that did
choose to participate and I there I
think there would be a lot of a lot of
pressure from internally from folks in
the states that chose not to to actually
join in and provide those opportunities
and for states that already have
programs there's 501 C 3s would be
grandfathered in so they could
automatically participate and expand
their programs and choose to do
something different in addition if they
wanted to and how big an increase would
the five billion potentially represent
to what states are currently seeing in
their 501c3 programs and compared to say
a state tuition tax credit program or
existing state scholarship programs is
this a big increase compared to what's
already out there well for all of the
participating states it would be a
significant boost to what they're doing
today
and you know the suggestion being that
states ultimately want to in need to
take take this opportunity seriously and
expand within their own state but I
think about the prospects for Florida
which is the state that I often cite is
the one that's most advanced in their
providing freedom and opportunities for
students this would be a boost to and in
fact I've heard from governor DeSantis
regularly on how important this would be
to their efforts there so if we combine
the existing Florida programs how much
do we know roughly how much debt
involves a year in terms of total
dollars I'm trying to recall and I'm the
the mental math is not coming back I
know that so quickly as as it should but
this would this would represent in
concert with what they're already doing
a very significant boost and would
really help to satisfy the demand that
they have that's built up around tens of
thousands of students let's talk about
Florida
for a moment if we can obviously former
Governor Jeb Bush was a huge proponent
of alternatives to the conventional
public school system and was very
popular for having accomplished that
with his
legislature in Florida what's going on
right now is they basically saved money
as they have in Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania saved about a half a
billion dollars and sorry about saving
money its repurposing the money to fit
the needs of the students we're not
wearing green eyeshades here and talking
about education but it does talk about
how more efficiently and more targeted
you can be with those resources in
Florida I read the statistics about 40%
of African Americans are the recipients
about 24 or 25 percent Hispanic and so
you're talking about many different
communities benefiting in the states
where these scholarships the funds are
already available and you all you also
see people talking to other people in
states you know relatives and friends
saying well why don't we have that here
you see a real grassroots pressure among
the parents and other stakeholders in
saying in saying this works somewhere
else why don't we have it here and that
is to the Secretary's point what will
well ultimately will need to happen as
people as they have with school choices
they have with charters sort of going up
the steps to state capitals and
impressing upon their leaders within
their states to help with the state
programs at the federal level we are
happy to be big Federalists who
recognize this does not expand the
federal role it is ro le it is just and
I and I have to push back even from the
right when we get criticism about your
just expanding the federal role in
education no this actually allows the
states and the local public the local
school systems and the parents indeed to
have more power and more flexibility
just by recognizing a tax credit on your
federal tax so let's stay with the
mechanics of that a bit because I think
it can help us think about these
concerns about the federal role how does
this actually work so I think is this
something that would exist in the US
Department of Education or how would
this actually operate it would just
simply be a portal
at Treasury so every state that chose to
participate would submit the list of one
or more 501 C 3 organizations to be the
scholarship granting organization and
recipient of those federal tax funds and
it would simply maintain the list it
would not create any new bureaucracy to
administer it the state's really
ultimately will administer you know
indirectly the through this 501c3
entities but it really is a vehicle and
as I said in my remarks it is a very
efficient and effective way to get
education funding directly to the
students that need it most and really
bypass a lot of bureaucratic sponge in
between I think it's a it's so simple
that it confounds people that's
Washington for you
Oh what about a skeptic who says what
sound that sounds pretty good but what
about fraudulent 501 C 3 's what if
states are getting taken to the cleaners
by somebody who's playing games how does
that work so the the legislation
requires that there be odd you know
auditing of the organization's and of
course 501 C 3 s first of all have to be
approved by the IRS to exist in the
first place and and there's a
requirement that 90% of the funds be
distributed so no more than 10% be used
in administration but other than that
it's it's a pretty simple approach and
you know many states that actually have
tax credit scholarship programs today
have really good models for this it's
not like you'd have to reinvent the
wheel other states could look to those
models and either emulate them or do
something slightly different but there's
there's so many good models already in
existence this is simply a way for them
to really grow them and in a very
meaningful way now you've both alluded
to concerns from the right about this
getting Washington being Washington
overreach getting Washington too
involved in education could you talk a
bit more about that given what you've
just described
what's the nature of those concerns and
where do you think they're getting it
wrong those critics from the right are
absolutely correct that the federal
government is already way too involved
in education nobody's going to disagree
with that including the Secretary of
Education and the president and the vice
president United States so that's a
given but there's so there's always a
suspicion that once the government is
way too intrusive invasive expensive and
expansive in the case of education in
many other areas of our life that this
would just open continue to open those
floodgates the the criticism is ill
founded respectfully because this does
not expand the federal role it gives
freedom and flexibility and I believe if
you just look past and people are just
there stop it's too way too linear and
constricted to say well it's your
federal tax form it's federal tax
dollars it's it's there are no strings
to that this is why you have these SG
o--'s in the states to decide who should
receive the monies and then how they
should be distributed or let them decide
how to use them
that is flexibility and freedom at its
core and but those concerns I respect
them I disagree with them but they also
are relatively muted to a couple of
restricted to just a couple of limited a
couple of places this has tremendous
support among many conservatives and
rank-and-file Republicans I would say
and also libertarians who look at the
freedom agenda in our education system
yeah I would just add to that every
major religious organization that it
deals with education is supporting this
proposal and as as have many of the
state-based allies all of the
state-based allies that have dealt with
this issue on a state-by-state basis
they see the benefit of really having a
vehicle for individuals to get funds
directly to scholarship granting
organization
that will ultimately benefit students
directly when the polling is there I
want to interject that too I mean people
who say look at the polling this is
popular this is not popular the polling
is irrefutable in terms of many most
Americans majorities of Americans
including key demographic groups who
would directly benefit from this they
the appetite is there or the public
opinion is there the public the public's
intent or mood willingness to try
something of this nature along with
school choice and charters and other
alternatives so for those who watch the
polls and pretend that as poll numbers
increase somewhere they must follow and
they're just not doing that here here
our politics is getting in the way of
public appetite so this is a wacky room
take take a minute you're a pollster to
give us give us a couple of the
particulars out of the polling data that
speak to you have them there in that bag
I can grab them but I he's so afraid to
touch a woman's hand I know and I could
I could grab them for you but we've all
seen the polling Darija vast majorities
of Hispanics African Americans public
school mothers saying that they support
when is described in objective terms
what this would provide and also just
when it's described to them 18 other
states have had it this is what has
happened to those states and more and
more I'm and I worked for many years I
had a client named Eva Moskowitz and her
her success charter network up in New
York or beginning and when she started
those she had just come back from a
Betsy DeVos type of conference out in
Jackson Hole I think where they were all
there and started her and they're just
enormous and why is it in the Armas
success because she built it and the
appetite just grew and the buzz grew and
then you had these labyrinths like lines
around blocks I I stood in them I
watched them I talked to the the parents
and grandparents in them just to get a
spot in the lottery it's random but they
were just hoping that chance would go
their way and and so they've had to
increase the other statistics I would
tell you because I thought this was a
very clever poll that someone did they
basically asking people what would you
do to improve
education for your kids and over 60% say
they would forego going out to eat for a
year they'd forego specialty coffee and
caffeine for a year go up for me or
forego yeah I know I'm speaking to a
pretty privileged audience in walk along
Keene Washington DC I mastered 17 god
bless us but but they would I mean they
are they are saying I would make the
sacrifice if the benefit for my child
were increased here we're saying you
don't have to make more of a sacrifice
the money will come to you just by
allowing this mechanism to be in place
secretary I'm curious you you've had the
opportunity to speak to a lot of folks
in the states and communities about this
proposal curious what struck you most
what what doubts have you heard
awesome curious where have you found the
warmest reception and what is really
stuck in your mind about it well there's
a really warm reception where ever I've
talked about it and we've continued to
convene leaders in states that many of
whom are involved in in this world
already but others who are sort of on
the fringe and are skeptical and the
more we talk about the possibilities and
the more we can help paint the picture
for how it can specific Taylor some of
their funds to their state to really
meet needs in their particular state I
have to say the enthusiasm continues to
grow and and I think that's really part
of the the key is to really help people
think more broadly about what this could
mean for individual students and in
state specific environments and I
recently was in Alaska and had the
opportunity to go to one of the most
remote villages there and as I was there
thinking about the challenges and the
opportunities for students there we
talked about the fact that what they
have to deal with and what they and
what's relevant to those students is
very very different than students as
geographically dispersed as Miami you
can't get much further away
graphically in our country than between
those two points and to think that we
would try to impose from Washington or
anywhere else a solution that is going
to answer the needs for those students
in Kivalina Alaska versus Miami Florida
suggest that we just haven't learned our
lesson over the last 50 years you know
you both have alluded to this I'm
curious
I mean we've certainly heard lots of
proposals from our progressive Brandt
friends that we need to spend more on
schools I could understand them saying
this is only five billion we also need
to triple title one or what have you but
I'm curious why there's such dead-set
opposition is something which sounds
like it is the opportunity to put more
money into schools serving kids and
needed well I would I would say it comes
down to a matter of control and those
who have interest self interest want to
control the resources they want to
control everything around the resources
and they don't want to let parents have
the kind and students have the kind of
freedom that we're talking about because
that means they lose control but I look
again at Florida and how that
environment in the last 20 years has
changed for students across the state
and those who are in a traditional
school have realized and noticed the
fact that as students make choices that
are right for them those students that
remain in those traditional schools
continue to do better and I would just
reference the fact that in 40 years
since the Department of Education was
founded we have spent over 1 trillion
dollars at the federal level alone
trying to close the achievement gap that
achievement gap has not narrowed one bit
and so to suggest that doing more of the
same thing is going to yield a different
result is Einstein's definition of
insanity we shouldn't do it we should
try something different
we're spending about 706 billion a year
I believe
in federal dollars K through 12 to begin
with one of the more one of the points
of consternation for me is how many of
the Democrats who are dead set against
sadly this type of proposals the
education freedom scholarship school
choice charters and weren't previously
is that they've shifted all the way to
free college and forgiving college debt
well what are we doing about every
single student who needs a quality
education now who should not be
constricted by their zip code or their
parents socioeconomic status that's
horrible and that's what's happening and
I think it's almost obfuscation in a
different way or maybe they're cleansing
their guilt of not of standing in the
way of providing other freedom and
freedom and and incredible opportunities
for education younger that we should all
just have free college and that's just
that's not fair on so many levels but
mainly because every student deserves in
education through the twelfth grade of
public education it is their right and
whether they choose to go to college
after that or can go to college or want
to go to college that's different that's
not that's less than half of the country
and it's much less than half of the
state in some places what about that
what about the fact that these funds
that we're talking about Ric and said
Madam Secretary would go to technical
and vocational perhaps would go to
alternatives to college and we I work in
the administration where we have
emphasized that in fact when I was
governor Pence's pollster when he was
running for governor and as governor the
number one most popular issue that he
was governing on was quote expanding
technical and vocational educational
opportunities it was through the roof
because not everybody is college
material that's great so go graduate
high school you walk this way and you're
going to law school or college and in
law school I walk that way and I'm going
to be a hairdresser the next day or a
technician or a mechanic or work in the
factory which now requires computer
skills or be a welder go make 40 bucks
an hour the day after you graduate from
high school sounds pretty good and we
just are not
respecting the diversity of choices
people make throughout their education
post 12th grade and I think we've got
we're in a movement here and we're
having conversations here and now about
helping them at the kindergarten level
to thrive and to have a better education
that's more responsive to them
individually in more response to the
21st century madam secretary one of the
things that you've both have touched
upon is that Union leadership has been
pretty critical this proposal you've
also noted on many prior occasions that
you've said look educational freedom is
good for teachers school choice should
be good for teachers Square that for me
how is this for teachers who are out
there working every day to make a
difference for kids why do you think
they should be supportive of this
proposal well first of all it will
afford them many more opportunities to
find their niche and they're fit as a
teacher I have talked with hundreds of
teachers across the country and I asked
them regularly what kinds of things do
they need to feel valued and supported
and what is the environment like for
them and almost to a person I hear that
while compensation is important what we
really need and what we really want is
to feel valued to have autonomy to make
decisions in our classrooms on behalf of
our students because we're the ones
closest to them and I think that in the
attempt to try to make things better
from a top-down approach much of their
flexibility and autonomy has been taken
away over the years and and and good
teachers need to be unleashed to really
be great at what they do and
commensurately teachers who shouldn't be
in the classroom who simply are a
mismatch for you know for what they're
doing probably should find a different
vocation and so this I think this
proposal will help teachers in
in a very fundamental way in that there
will be alternative paths and
alternative learning environments that
may be a much better fit for them and
will allow them to be compensated and
recognized accordingly for any of this
to matter obviously this has to become
law and right now as you both have noted
several times today
DC is a relatively polarized place the
parties have very different stances on
this proposal the White House and House
representatives are in a conflict shall
we say what's what's the path forward
for this to become law for this to for
this to happen well you may even ask
them I think the country is watching how
they spend their time and your money and
we all choose that in our personal lives
how we spend our time how we spend our
money they work for us they don't seem
to be here very often and when they are
they're focused on other things and
other people places and things I would
say and that's unfortunate but they work
for you so the question really for the
country is how do you want them to spend
your time do you think this is a
worthwhile piece of legislation to put
forth and just work through the
committees and I would say to them what
are you afraid of if you want to vote
against it vote against it but give
others an opportunity to even get there
I think they're afraid of taking a
negative vote that basically puts them
at odds with millions of schoolchildren
who can potentially benefit from this
and so they don't the way they spend
their time and their current issues
accepted has been pretty remarkable to
me as somebody who was in the
infrastructure meeting with the
Democratic leadership in the committee
heads is somebody who works on health
care every day will be with the
president in Florida on on Thursday when
he talks about Medicare another health
care building-block what are we afraid
of in the process of actually pushing
this forward in a bipartisan way the way
first step back was the way the opioid
and drug crisis were
you may just help that many more school
children either in your state or
elsewhere and this is the one where they
truly have I believe partisan blinders
on when it comes to educational freedom
and I would say there's no excuse I'm
not making a partisan comment I said
it's disheartening and somewhat
maddening particularly giving how given
how hypocritical many of them are
otherwise talking about helping
communities of color otherwise how it's
saying I'm for the children and for the
children for the children this is the
fundamental right of every child to have
a quality education that gives them a
passport to the future and the dignity
that goes with that the last thing I
would just say in this vein is the
president wrote a book in 2000 where he
talked about education freedom and he
didn't he didn't call education freedom
scholarships but he was talking about
alternatives he was talking about that
were failing kids in our educational
system and in his first State of the
Union he said if we could put a man on
the moon and dig out the Panama Canal
canal and win two world wars we ought to
be able to figure out a way to provide
quality education to each student so
we're ready at the White House I we can
get him to sign that today but we need
real bipartisanship and we need
priorities to put the kids first Madam
Secretary what you know what's the
strategy to kind of push on that well
your allies in the States your
colleagues what would you encourage them
to do how do you try to get this ball
rolling well it is it is a matter of
personal diplomacy in in many cases you
really do need to help paint the picture
of what can be because the issue has
become very polarized due to the
opposition on the other side but I in in
the meetings that I've had in States
there is a real will to work with their
particular delegation members and and in
really urge the passage of this
legislation kellyanne's absolutely right
they need the the folks up on Capitol
Hill need to ask the hard questions
about how and why they can and should
oppose something like this opportunity
all you need to do is spend time with
one or more students that have had the
opportunity to have their life
trajectory changed and it's very hard to
make the argument not to support it and
I urge and encourage all of them to do
so I know there's a great resistance to
that but it is it is the right thing and
I for those who have the opportunity
every member of Congress has had the
opportunity for their children or
grandchildren to go to the schools that
they deem right for them they should
extend that same opportunity to every
every child and every family in this
nation all right with that let's go
ahead and open up for a few questions
we've got a couple of colleagues coming
around microphones
I would ask oh when you get the mic
identify yourself by name and
affiliation and then ask a question if
we get about 10 or 15 seconds in and I
don't see a question coming well give
somebody else a shot yes sir Thank You
Leon peace Thank You secretary post my
question is given the need for in the
support for a lifelong education with
this of scholarships would they be
available for post-secondary higher
education and for a graduate school
especially given the need for workers to
be retrained as senior citizens in some
cases to to enter new new opportunities
well it's a great question this proposal
is really focused on k-12 education and
for the states that actually wrap in
pre-k to their k-12 program they could
they could target that around preschool
as well but it really is focused on the
the k-12 years but your point is a good
one and we should really be looking at
education as a lifelong pursuit
there are some states that have
implemented education savings accounts
which of course can be used to tart to
customize your education and if you
don't use up all of the dollars in a
year you can roll it forward and Arizona
for example has an ESA that if you still
have a balance at the conclusion of your
k12 years you can use it for higher
education
states that participated in this may
look at doing something similar Brenda
thank you very much I'm a student from
Teachers College Columbia University
actually I have two very short questions
so a is that there's a we find that
there is a gap between the academic
skills that you gained in school and the
skills that are required at work so the
knowledge gap like how would you close
the knowledge gap secondly because I'm a
personally attorney student studying in
the States many say that the trade war
has affected the the visa like I just
wonder what's the standing point of the
Department of Education for during you
know even the trade conflicts like
what's your standing point in this issue
thank you so much your first question
about closing the knowledge gap many of
the schools that I've had opportunity to
visit are approaching their education
and learning differently for students
and acknowledging that some of these
gaps exist and so they are really taking
a different approach and the more
freedom we interject into education
across the country I believe the more
responses and different approaches we'll
have to first of all acknowledging that
and then addressing it and allowing
students to find that right fit but we
do have a real challenge today because I
think we've we've become too focused on
one approach at the expense of really
preparing students in a rapidly changing
world for
comes next lemon my name is Jehan a
first year at American University and
I'm an intern at the Center for
education reform and there's a lot of
talk about funding but as a student we
don't see a lot of the media problems
solved before us and like the the
problems graduate unemployment or mental
health in schools or stuff like that but
what do you think is the largest problem
in K to 12 schools or even university
that can't be solved with more funding
well I think per this proposal we don't
have enough freedom in k-12 education
today freedom for the families and
students that aren't able to make the
choices that that many who are wealthy
and connected are able to make and so
it's a matter of really being fair to
all students not only fair but allowing
all students the vehicle and opportunity
to find their right fit we have as a we
are as a country spending more than
almost every country in the world on k12
education and yet we still rank 24th
25th and 40th in the measures around
reading science and math and so doing
the same thing and putting more money
behind it and expecting a different
result
I I don't think I know that's not going
to solve the issue or the problem yeah
and Edward Hutchins from the Heartland
Institute as you know the Department of
Education Department of Labor has
recently is going to issue new rulings
on apprenticeships allowing private
nonprofits as well as businesses to set
up the requirements for apprenticeships
to deal with the incredible disconnect
between education and the needs of the
free market jobs careers with especially
with exponential technology and as you
know cups like career-wise Colorado are
trying to connect kids in high school
with businesses to do the learn and earn
would the freedom Scholar
ships help facilitate this move to
apprenticeships to allow the 2/3 of
Americans who don't go on to college to
actually get good careers and jobs yes
yes ok that was DB yes they could indeed
be used to facilitate apprenticeships
and in fact I think it's a that is a
really important opportunity for states
to look at and I'll just quickly say on
apprenticeships and skilling and
rescaling and and all of that workforce
development the six million plus or
seven million plus available jobs more
than people looking for them there's no
question that we're doing a
whole-of-government approach obviously
it's a partner of Education Department
of Labor on top of it early on in this
administration we invited to the White
House a number of Governors and cabinet
secretaries etc but I'm John
Hickenlooper then the governor of
Colorado Democrat who somehow has been
forced out of the race
because he's a two-term successful
governor of a swing state but anyway who
emphasize that's okay
ironic but that I think the one that you
mentioned in Colorado is one of many
examples that are popping up across
these states because the market is
necessitating that and I did want to
make sure that we amplified today the
value we see in after the K to 12 or
during the nine to twelve those
acquiring a skill set not just pushing
everybody in into college who you know
who has other employment opportunities
but this is something that we've been
doing in a bipartisan basis with the
states even if we can't get its own here
although I think that Ivanka Trump has
led the way here too with the Perkins
grants and some other measures but as
you can see what the secretary is laying
out today through the education freedom
scholarships is just the latest and one
of the greatest point pieces of the
overall education freedom agenda we've
been working on that for quite a while
and I think it's one of the bright line
distinctions between us and the other
side okay one last question
yes Thank You Caleb Dalton with Alliance
defending freedom Center for academic
freedom thank you so much as you could
tell by the word
freedom I love a lot the ideas of
freedom but I I do have a question as
you implement this have have you
considered or are there already measures
in place that would protect for example
religious schools or religious
nonprofits ability to have access to
these funds great question and in fact
yes the draft language does include a
specific protection against religious
discrimination and as it's been said
religious discrimination is not a good
policy so making that assumption we have
also been very explicit to say it is not
an option if states elect to be a part
of this program terrific Madam Secretary
counselor thank you so much for your
time today
[Applause]
I'm gonna ask the audience remain seated
for a moment while we chant transition
to the next panel thank you so much
join
well good morning my name is KNAT
Malchus I'm an education policy scholar
here at AEI and I get to take us through
round two our panel with State decision
makers and we have an excellent panel
and I'm going to sort of introduce them
now and then we're gonna jump right into
a discussion of school choice in the
States and what education freedom
scholarships might mean there so I have
three state policymakers here today
Kimberly Yee is the 36th treasurer of
Arizona and we're glad to have you here
she stewards a 40 billion dollar state
budget and make sure that the checks go
to whom they need to go to Treasury has
a number of firsts under her belt that
are worth mentioning she's the first
Asian American elected to statewide
office in Arizona she's the first
chinese-american Republican woman to win
a major statewide office in the United
States
she was Senate majority leader in
Arizona and not the first but notably
followed Sandra Day O'Connor about four
decades later so that's worth mentioning
she also as I said she chaired the
Senate Education Committee and helped
create the nation's first education
savings account in 2011 and
interestingly has a little bit of a
pattern I think that you worked on the
executive team of the former Arizona
State Treasurer Dean Martin and now you
hold that post and you were an analyst
for the Arizona Senate Committee on
education which you would later chair so
some grass roots work and then heading
thanks for being here
john de berry is a representative of the
90th district and Tennessee General
Assembly he represents Memphis and he's
been there a while let's put it this way
he started in 1995 when I lived in
Tennessee so that's been quite a while
since I've been in DC and the assembly
he's been a member of several committees
including the Education Committee and
the curriculum testing and innovation
subcommittee and he also serves as the
Democratic leader pro tempore
Mike tours I is our last leader he's the
Speaker of the Pennsylvania House of
Representatives and represents the 28th
district in Allegheny County speaker
tours I has been a member of the House
since 2001 and was elected speaker in
2015 and he's also done groundbreaking
work in Pennsylvania on their school
choice initiatives
he led efforts with Pennsylvania
business leaders to implement a 50
million dollar Opportunity Scholarship
Tax Credit which targets children in low
performing schools and while he was
House Majority Leader he doubled the
size of the education improvement tax
credit the other AI TC yes in
Pennsylvania from fifty to a hundred
million dollars so but Before we jump
into questions I just lay out some of
the differences in the school choice
landscape in the states Tennessee has
been fighting in recent years to get
programs up and they did just pass
another one for Memphis and Nashville
specifically in in Pennsylvania there
are two tax credit scholarships that I
mentioned already they have 50,000
students plus participating in them
Arizona is sort of the heavy hitter with
four different tax credit scholarships
programs tens of thousands of students
and like I said the first ESA which is
one of the most mature there also have a
very rare program of universal
eligibility for their tax credit
scholarship in in Arizona so a wide
variety of states and contexts speaker
tours I if I could start with you
reflecting on the conversation that we
heard in the past hour I wonder what
your take is given that the states have
been doing the heavy lifting on school
choice for about three decades right
they've made all the progress that we've
seen and this is an opportunity with the
education freedom scholarships for the
federal government come in and we heard
discussions about some folks being a
little wary of that how does that play
out down the line when there may be less
school choice friendly folks
in the in the White House or in the
administration my question to you is as
a state leader that's been doing this
work is this a good thing or a bad thing
for school choice in the States and why
or why not
yeah it's a decidedly good thing and
first and foremost the proposal the
education freedom scholarships that the
secretary and her team have put together
is a mirror to a certain extent on on
work that has been done in Pennsylvania
Florida and Arizona and so the
laboratories of democracy have already
shown that it works in Pennsylvania we
have a robust Education Improvement Tax
Credit scholarship it's up to 135
million this past year and on top of
that we have the 55 million dollar
Opportunity Scholarship so a total of
about 190 million we've increased the
limits for income for families to make
use of them fifty thousand students were
able to receive some scholarship another
just shy of another fifty thousand
didn't get them another 145 million was
left off the table from businesses that
wanted to get the tax credits it will
work it will work in all 50 states and
it will work with the partnership with
the federal government and here's the
key I thought the secretary made so many
important points but here's the key in
what I believe and I hope I had this
number right in a four point five
trillion dollar budget and the federal
level five billion I know we throw
around the term billion but five billion
in tax credits tax credits people are
still paying their tax liability they're
just directing into opportunities for
kids to make a decision to go to a
different school that fits them that
many more affluent folks have that's the
fundamental issue my wife and I'm Lydia
is a pediatrician with three boys - one
who graduated public high school one who
graduated from a struggling Catholic
school but that's where he wanted to go
and it was a good thing
and our youngest who's in 11th grade is
in the public school but we could afford
it many other folks do not have that
opportunity and there are parents and
grandparents and Guardians all across
the United States of America that want
to have that fundamental opportunity to
send their child that they are
responsible for to the best place for
that child and the secretary and the
team are taking that school choice
movement and saying we ought to make it
national and work with the states I
think it's a great opportunity
representative to Barry you've been in
the fight for school choice programs in
Tennessee and you have some fresh scars
to show for it I imagine Tennessee has
two programs but a long way to go to
sort of catch up with either
Pennsylvania or Arizona's progress my
question to you is with the political
realities on the ground in Tennessee how
do you think the state might react and
use the education freedoms get a
scholarship opportunity were to become
law well I think the misnomer is that
the parents don't want it they really do
and that it's not going to benefit the
children it really will what's what's
happening in the state of Tennessee is
what's happening all over the country
and those individuals who have a
personal stake in the funds that we
allocate to educate our children are not
necessarily concerned many times about
what happens to the children we have in
the state of Tennessee what I call and
especially in Memphis a large urban area
and the demographics speak for
themselves for the schoolhouse to
jailhouse pipeline is is wide open and
we're putting less and less children are
in higher education or in positioning
them so they can make a living so what I
think we have in the state of Tennessee
is what we have across the country we've
got to deal with the perception that you
know the the the calling cry is public
money and the private schools and so on
and so forth
not necessarily taking to heart
that it's public money to take care of
our children and I think as Secretary
said we've got to get the money
concentrate on the children not the
system and that's what we're doing I was
accused of when we were talking about
this in this debate it was said well
what's going to happen in the state of
Tennessee is they're going to
cherry-pick you know get the best
children in this school the best
children in that school at which my
response was education within itself in
many places is true all kids don't go to
law school all kids don't go to medical
school all kids don't become architects
or even teachers in essence those
individuals who are prepared for those
various professions and for those
various disciplines those are the ones
that go there what we've got to do is
put more cherries on the tree and that's
what we're not doing we've got to get
more children ready to be picked to go
to school to have those opportunities
and I think that's where the battle lies
in the state of Tennessee we've got to
create and enhance and fortify the
perception that this is a matter of
national defense if you please and most
certainly the strengthening of our state
treasury in Arizona you've got a very
different political realities on the
ground especially compared to Tennessee
and you have a much more robust system
of school choice and like I said earlier
you have for tax credits kosha programs
my question is if the ef-s were to
become a reality what do you think
Arizona would do with this you know new
tailwind and it seems to me that you
could you know you could build your
programs up by increasing the amounts
that are offered to kids or you could
build them out by increasing the breadth
of programs and more participation or
you could sort of build options that
they might include and so maybe focus on
concurrent enrollment or pre-k and so
forth if Arizona had this tailwind what
do you think they would do with it well
let me first just say that the
education financial scholarships have
worked in our state and we have been a
robust school choice state we're
celebrating 25 years of charter schools
in Arizona and for this federal proposal
it is not only good education policy
it's good tax policy and for us to
continue to enhance that in Arizona with
this opportunity we would be able to do
more with what we already have put
forward as a foundation one of the
things that the experiences I had in the
state legislature before I can't became
the state treasurer was always designing
what works for the monies that were
available right and the opportunities
there so we wouldn't have as many
boundaries with this because we would
have that much more to use and be able
to have more kids in those schools that
they want to be in right now there are
some prohibitions for the types of kids
that can have and what we call an
empowerment scholarship and one of those
is that you if you're a preschooler you
have to be a preschooler with a
disability if you're a kindergartner you
have to be a kindergartner with a
disability let's remove that and just
let all of those preschoolers and all of
those kindergarteners be able to choose
the school of their choice and so again
this would allow us to enhance our
existing programs in Arizona yeah I'm
interested in the the form of the tax
credit scholarship so there's tax credit
scholarships and we have more
traditional voucher programs and then
there's also education savings accounts
and I'll just ask any of the three of
you EFS sort of comes as a tax credit
scholarship it requires the state if
they haven't set up one to identify the
501 C 3s or the the scholarship granting
organizations the S gos
do you think that that format may sort
of privilege the tax credit scholarship
maybe to the I don't know if they they
deserve an advantage but to you know the
less likelihood that ESA S or vouchers
would continue and D of you that is a
problem or an issue well I can speak for
Arizona I think when the secretary
earlier shared that the
way to sell this piece is to hear the
testimonials of the very families who
have been benefited from not only our
essays but also other school choice
opportunities we have in Arizona that
tells the story so what would this do
this would allow us to build that bridge
to those who might not already you know
have this opportunity we could enhance
the existing programs and we could bring
forward a new marketing tool quite
frankly because if they have the
experience with these wonderful
opportunities of school choice let's
share that story let's allow the other
families that might have heard a story
or two that may have been incorrect
about the you know the opportunities
these families had let them hear about
the families who have benefited who have
succeeded and who are staying in the
schools of their choice speaker tours
that I wanted to follow up and just give
you the opportunity to answer the same
question I asked earlier treasure
treasure ye you have a couple of tax
credit scholarships what do you think
Pennsylvania would be able to do with
EFS I mean five years after the EFS
would had passed would your tax credit
scholarships the you know bill up in
value would they be be expanded would
they be for more options where would you
think the push would be in Pennsylvania
without a doubt they would enhance our
existing educational improvement at
credit scholarships and our Opportunity
Scholarship tax credits without a doubt
because you could partner them off and
and you would actually be able to do two
things you would be able to expand the
pool of families that get those
scholarships and the amounts that they
get so you actually believe that you
would continue to create waiting lists
because it would become more more
attractive you never quite catch up
right because I think people want that
choice people of all backgrounds all you
know rural city suburban one
opportunities to do what's best for
their child and I think the other thing
that you asked is is it going to crowd
out other
other stratagems other mechanism yeah
other mechanisms for school choice we
have a purple so that we're putting out
as a as a pilot program or a prototype
for the city of Harrisburg
it's our capital city about sixty five
hundred students in that that particular
School District seven percent of the
students are testing proficient in
algebra nine percent or testing
proficient in biology thirteen percent
are testing proficient in English that's
unacceptable the secretary was gracious
enough to come to the capital city and
we went and saw Harrisburg Elementary
Catholic elementary school Kate Kate
through Aid and those students were
across the board minority students
low-income students many single-parent
families or the grandparents you know
we're doing much of the you know the
edge you know the rearing or the
education they were wearing uniforms
there was great discipline great love
great learning environment and those we
heard of a particular single mom with
two boys in eighth grade in seventh
grade
who said it was the single most
important decision in her life and that
without the scholarship which was about
maybe one one-third the amount so she
had to come up with the other amount for
that tuition cuz it's not cheap you know
they had even that that that school she
said it was a single most important
decision and that she had her kids on
the path where they were gonna be able
to succeed in life you can see it you
can see it tangibly so I if I'm a
policymaker keep moving forward whatever
your stratagem is whatever your
mechanism is keep moving forward because
is this good representative said there
are a lot of people who want that choice
representative area I'm interested in in
states that aren't as far along don't
have developed programs some states
don't have any school choice programs
and their politics don't make them very
likely to bring them on how much do you
think that if the ef-s program
came forward into law as we're looking
at how much of a help would it be in
states that currently offer no school
choice process I'm think first of all
we've got to change their perception the
debate has gone on forever I've been in
office for 25 years we've been talking
about this forever we go on and on and
on in the conversation the conversation
gets convoluted and the public gets
confused at the book as to what we're
really trying to do and that's what's
happening all over this country I'm an
old guy my dad marched with dr. King I
was somewhere back in the crowd as a
teenage boy when my dad integrated the
schools in Crockett County in 1968 as
the president of the n-double a-c-p it
was about school choice it wasn't that
the school that we were going to was
insufficient the teachers were wonderful
it was a great school but it was a
segregated Society that was the school
we were sent to whether we liked it or
not because of all the various reasons
that's where we were supposed to be my
dad said that's not right we're changing
this we integrated the school in 1968 a
great experience with the kids there at
Crockett County High this has gone on
throughout my life my children my eldest
daughter is an attorney my youngest
daughter is a therapist neither one of
them would be who they are had I not had
the ability to take them out of a
schools which were insufficient to
educating them and preparing them for
life I got two jobs and I sent them to
school and I paid the tuition because
it's my responsibility to educate my
children when parents begin to realize
is these are their tax dollars these are
their children these are their schools
that they pay for these are
opportunities that are funded by the
money that they work hard and give so
that the government can properly use it
and when you have something called a
failing school and we throw that term
around like it's normal that's not
normal
and what when as soon as people get
enough of it and and decide that they
want their children to have better it's
going to change across the state so this
is this is an evolution of
school choice as far as my experience is
concerned going all the way back to the
60s it's still going on and until
parents have the right to say where
their children are going to go so that
they can have the opportunities that
they need then we'll we'll keep talking
about this hopefully we get the
perception change so folks will
understand this is not about unions this
is not about professions this is about
the children and from the children we
work back to who it takes to make it
happen so I would have taken a minute
and zoom in a little bit on that on the
weeds that's where I'm most comfortable
so you know we talked about it well we
have these education freedom
scholarships we have tax credit
scholarships and then we give
scholarships to kids but there's a big
institution in that on the in between
there and that's these scholarship
granting organizations part of the
strategy behind this bill is that by
allowing States to determine who those
scholarship granting organizations are
and what they can do that they have
control over these programs in enlarge
in a larger aspect with some guardrails
my question especially in Pennsylvania
in Arizona what guides your choices of
scholarship granting organizations how
does the state decide who should get
them in why because they seem to play a
pretty central role in these programs in
Arizona we call them school tuition
organizations and they're 501 C 3s so
because they are if I want to see theory
the state gets out of the way once they
are granted as an organization and then
there
their role is to ensure that there is
accountability on the side of the
financials and if you were to go to the
ESA S which are empowerment scholarships
the state treasurer's office is the
financial manager of those accounts
while the state Department of Education
is the program manager of those accounts
between the two state agencies we ensure
that those dollars are being used for
the very purposes so that the
accountability is there so that the
taxpayers know that they're being used
for the purpose that was intended at the
same time it allows for the program to
continue to grow because they
see that there is a real strong program
there with rails to guard against fraud
and one of the things that I found early
on in looking at our stos is that
families find the right sto to go to and
that is their choice continuing down
locally even to the family so in Arizona
we have a number of stos and these
school tuition organizations are around
every single corner of the state so if
one resident wants to go to the northern
part of Arizona and go to that sto they
can do that it really doesn't matter
because they all play a very important
role in making sure the funds are
available like a backpack to go on the
backs of that student wherever they
choose to go to school you know these
scholarship organizations the the key
thing is is that when they applied to
make use of the tax credits and to give
out the scholarships is that the money
is in fact going to is going to schools
that are providing a scholarship to
those students to be able to attend
there so the function of the scholarship
organization is very defined very
defined and the key thing is is that
that you're looking over that that they
are in fact sending the money to the
school for that student to get that
scholarship and and it's it's actually
easy to audit and easy to if you if you
and we have a department that doesn't
under the Department of Education that
watches that and you have to be approved
in the first place and then secondly you
you get watched and you have to send
sending reports but that's the key and
keep in mind I just want to give this
some context here in the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania we spend over thirty
billion dollars of state and local tax
dollars all approved by the state either
on on a statewide level where we can
powers to school districts to you know
have taxes and raise money for public
schools over 30 billion dollars for
public education K through 12 we're in
the top let me just give you these
we're in the top where the third in
adjusted average teacher salary for
public schools third and adjusted
average starting salary for public
schools out of 50 states third in
adjusted average teacher salary to
median household income third and
adjusted per student public school
spending in Pennsylvania the amount of
scholarships we have is a hundred and
ninety million dollars in tax grants we
are less than 1% of what we are spending
on public education and over thirty
billion dollars if we're going to talk
about accountability I'd like to take
maybe even a closer look at the thirty
billion dollar where we're spending on
public education K through 12
then this 190 million that we're
allowing for tax credits and these
people that are trying to get the tax
credits and give out the scholarships to
people with a mission what's the mission
allow families lower and middle-income
families to be able to go to choices in
education uh a lot of those folks any
day they're doing the right thing so I'm
curious about the relationship between
state lawmakers and policymakers and the
representatives that you send to Capitol
Hill and how you might be able to put
pressure on them or get them to voice
the concerns of the folks that you
represent particularly on this issue and
I'd also just be curious generally about
the political climate in your state
versus the political climate they're
going to and what all those forces mean
for the likelihood of the education
freedom scholarships getting traction on
Capitol Hill well I think that one of
the aspects of this proposal is that it
respects federalism and it allows for
the states to design the program as they
wish and if you look back in Arizona in
1997 when we created charter schools and
open enrollment and the school the tax
credit the tax credit individually as
well as corporate
we gave a little peace to both parties
quite frankly and so it allowed us to
reach across the aisle though the
proposal was being advanced by the
Republicans our Democrat friends were
alongside the proposal because we
allowed for the public schools to use a
little bit of this as well to advance
their tax credits for public schools for
instance they could use it for fees or
banned or uniforms or you know other
extracurricular related advancements and
so this could be designed in a way where
it works for both parties and in a way
where our public school advocates and
our school choice advocates come
together around the table to design what
works best for that state I would just
suggest I know this is a fairly uh I'm
not here in Washington DC so I don't you
know know the lay of the land as those
folks who are here but I would begin
with the Senate majority leader and I
would ask Senator McConnell who I
think's a thoughtful person and the the
diligent public elected official I would
make this a priority I would say let's
get this through the Senate with
alacrity why because once it passes a
chamber and as a as a speaker of the
house would you know I have experience
with this in former Majority Leader once
it passes a chamber
it changes the chessboard because it has
a level of a reality a body in the
United States Congress actually passed
it and it puts pressure on the other
body and that pressure needs to come on
speaker Pelosi because she's a lot of
talk and she's not a lot of delivery I
bet her kids I don't know this but I'll
bet her kids went to private schools
I'm sure her entire circle of friends
kids went to private schools so sue she
want to offer that opportunity for a lot
of other parents and grandparents and
Guardians throughout the United States
of America or she just about protecting
the establishment
interests I'll bet the latter but let's
make her make the choice but that has to
begin with the Senate passing the bill I
don't I don't want to pretend to get
into the middle of the toxic atmosphere
that exists there in Washington because
all it does is increase the toxicity in
in the state of Tennessee we don't have
the infrastructure that either of these
states have since we're just getting
started and there are a lot of a lot of
uncharted territory that we have to go
through in implementing our policies of
school choice but I think that you know
we make stuff more complicated than it
actually is because when we start
talking about accountability and
measurable as results everybody in this
room business people academia or
whatever we might be that's the way we
operate in the American system we are
accountable for the funds that we
receive the funds that are allocated the
funds that go to education in May are
well over a billion dollars in in my
County and and it what if we started
becoming accountable and we looked at
results that were measurable and that
the money was doing what it was supposed
to do I think that until until here
again as the secretary said until we
move the system until we move all the
bullies till we move the people who have
who have self-interests the folks who
are locked in their silos and they are
deeply rooted in their own opinion
rather than what is best where we get
nowhere at some point in time if we're
going to have a generation that's going
to be competing we're going to get away
from being number 40 in the world in the
laughingstock of the world we've got all
of these advantages and all of these
blessings and we're not passing it on to
our offspring if that's going to happen
then we've got to be adults maturity is
doing what's best even if it's not what
I want and folks who get elected to
office are going to have to stop acting
like a bunch of children sit down at the
table and act like adults and solve this
problem
I believe kelsa Conway said hope springs
eternal so I have a question on back on
the tax credit scholarships
I'm studied school choice programs quite
a bit there's a lot of things to like
about Tax Credit scholarships one of the
things generally across the program's to
not like is that they're fairly lowly
funded vouchers and certainly essays are
more highly funded I just wonder what
what to make of this especially from
Pennsylvania and Arizona to
representative to Barry who doesn't have
a tax credit scholarship yet what are
some of the difficulties with getting
these scholarship amounts up high enough
to really help especially low-income
folks leader tours I you mentioned the
the woman who was getting a scholarship
for about a third of tuition you know if
you're a low-income family in Harrisburg
coming up with four or five thousand
dollars a year stuff ya know it's a it's
it's a very good point but you have to
get the foot in the door and it is
saving lives because there's fifty
thousand students in Pennsylvania who
wouldn't otherwise have this choice and
would we like to see it expanded to more
individuals yes no here's what we did we
had a bill House bill 800 passed both
the House and the Senate had bipartisan
support in the house was just
Republicans in the Senate went to the
governor's desk Wall Street Journal
editorial eyes three times in favor of
it asked the governor to sign it and he
vetoed it what it would have done it
would have increased our our educational
improvement tax credit scholarship by a
hundred million it would be like a
booster you know to take it from up to
two hundred and ten million dollars we
read one hundred and ten million dollars
we've subsequently got it up to 135
million dollars but to take it up to two
hundred and ten million dollars and then
we had an escalator which we are
borrowing from Florida we didn't come up
with the idea and it would
it would have been a 10% increase if
there were enough subscriptions there's
always enough subscriptions and for
students and that want these
scholarships and and then that would
have increased every year bite you know
10% so it was a multiplier right that
was one one of the reasons the governor
vetoed it
we have to continue to keep moving
forward we are taking a different
approach with this Harrisburg prototype
we're doing a more direct scholarship
it's gonna be 50% of basic education
funding split in part by the local
school district and by the state in
Harrisburg instance it'll amount to
about eighty two hundred dollars forty
one hundred and forty one hundred in
mind however for the local school
district we are not changing well what
you call their average daily membership
count in fact we're going to be
increasing it because we'll throw in the
number of students already in private
schools into that number when we
allocate the state tax dollars so on a
per pupil basis say 25% of the students
decide to choose these scholarships they
would be educating for a higher dollar
amount 75% of the kids which means that
on a per pupil basis that mount goes up
and right now Harrisburg is spending
22,000 when I say Harrisburg itself it's
both state and local tax dollars 22,000
per student I already gave you the
results that's well above the national
average and in addition 60% of that
amount is coming from state tax dollars
while 40% of it is coming from local tax
dollars that we've empowered them to do
so III do think that there's a variety
of approaches to take I don't think you
sit on any one approach to school choice
the treasurer talked about 25 years of
charter schools in the state of Arizona
the charter schools are another approach
but but if you're saving lives why
wouldn't you continue to pursue it
Treasury I'm interested in
in your comments just on the difficulty
of giving these scholarship amounts you
know hi well the 90% of the basic state
aid is what we use for essays which are
empowerment scholarships so it really is
saving the taxpayers funds that would
otherwise go to a full 100% public
school student that's one aspect
secondly if you take a look at what
parents are receiving they this allows
them to truly take a look at what the
state is giving them and choosing no
matter where they live whatever zip code
they live in the school of their choice
the school that best fits their child's
needs that is a concept that we have to
remember when we talk about freedom and
and who is to say that for any nonprofit
because as we were talking about school
tuition organizations are a 501c3 who in
America has a cap on how much you should
be able to give to you know your
favorite nonprofit and and so we should
be able to look at expanding that if we
already have that in existence in our
state and and be able to have a tax
payer allocate more to that school
tuition organization so that more kids
can benefit from this great program one
of the things that I try to do when I
work through the legislative process in
advocating for this is to really talk
about how these stories really do sell
the initiative and we have had 25 years
of stories to tell in Arizona and truly
some of these stories bring you to tears
because of how families have escaped
from a system that has just pushed their
child back sometimes grade levels back
and now they have the freedom to choose
the school of their choice for instance
we have a number of communities where if
the the school of their you know zip
code is a failing school they've had to
be trapped in that school for all of
these years suddenly with our
empowerment scholarships and with our
school choice options in Arizona they're
able to go to another school
that works best for them that where they
can succeed those are the stories that
will sell this initiative not only in
the States but also on that hill and I
think that that really is something that
Arizona is committed to do to be able to
share the you know decades of experience
that we've had on school choice so
different school choice private school
choice options often have different
targeting some of the programs Arizona
has a Tax Credit scholarship that's
universal
that is rare most of them are targeted
either to low-income students they're
targeted to students with disabilities
some targeted to students they're
bullied some targeted to low-performing
schools or districts in a state as state
leaders dealing with these issues how do
you think about the trade-offs and those
different eligibility rules and for a
state that's sort of considering to take
a first foray into these things where
would you suggest is the sweet spot in
terms of program eligibility well one of
the myths is that if we open up the caps
or if we open up the number of students
and remove the prohibitions that we have
that all of the kids from the public
schools are going to run into the
private school landscape it's that's not
the case we've had ESA s in Arizona on
the books since 2011 and you can see
that there has been movement where
parents are able to walk to the schools
of their choice with their children but
it's not this exodus from the public
school system so that really does speak
to the fact that it's about freedom you
can choose to use it or you can choose
not to use it
but allowing States to have that ability
to design the program of their choice
goes back to the you know the the
respect that the states should have in
designing the program that fits best for
this new program and for Arizona again
we have a long-standing history with
school choice we feel this would just
enhance those programs and allow us to
to have more students benefit from
school choice if the public schools look
at poor children and
and gave them the opportunities that
they absolutely have to have if they're
going to escape poverty in the cycle of
poverty then we wouldn't be constantly
using those children as as our imaginary
target for every program that we come up
with well we're going to help poor
children with this well we're gonna help
poor children with this we've got to get
off of this bandwagon and and simply say
we've got to do what's best for all
students regardless of who they are now
the reason we start with with poor
children in the state of Tennessee
children who whose families qualify for
temporary federal assistance it's
because those children have been
woefully neglected those children are
the ones who fill up the prisons they're
the ones who fill up the gangs they're
the ones who have not been given the
attention that they need remediated so
that they can learn to read better I
have given kids a dollar for every
report card cycle since first grade
watch them go through 12 years of school
have their diploma in hand with honors
and they can't make a 14 or 15 on the AC
T and then we want to say it's that
child's fault when that child has set in
our system under our tutelage under our
care for 12 years and we have failed to
get them ready so number one we got to
stop using the poor children so that we
can appease our conscious or so we can
easily or whatever and simply do what's
right and say that we in America are
failing our children we are not
competing with the rest of the world we
have a global economy a child anywhere
in the world can get on an airplane and
be in America within a matter of hours
and set right beside a child who has
been here all of their lives applying
for the same exact job with better
skills and until we start looking at
this as a matter of the preservation of
our Republic of our national defense and
taking care of our citizens we're going
to just keep spinning our wheels and
that's kind of where we are right now
well speaker tours I want to
to you on this question of targeting but
first I want to just ask about
Tennessee's recent experience because
you have a very sort of odd set of
targets in this latest bill and that's
Memphis and Nashville
instead of the state so I'm just a
little curious how that unfolded and why
it unfolded because there are those who
absolutely believe that because this is
public money even though we have
scholarships Tennessee promise that
takes public money and a child can take
that money to any school private or
public that they wish to get a good
education and this has worked
wonderfully throughout the state of
Tennessee educating so many young people
we want to do the same thing as far as
high school is concerned or elementary
is is concerned and there are those who
say that this is absolutely not right it
is against the public interest as a
matter of fact there's a bill filed
already to repeal and to undo what we
did last year so it's it's that attitude
and perception that this is ours to
control and in my opinion you have many
many wonderful teachers many wonderful
schools people who are giving their
absolute best taking money out of their
pocket but if when you have a systemic
problem like we have where there are
organizations that their very existence
depends upon controlling those funds
they're gonna fight for dear life to
control them and that's what's happening
in Tennessee and I've been sure that's
what's happening all over the country so
I'm just interested to follow up and
there's one more because it it seems at
first it was a Tennessee wide program
well then it was scaled down to these
two counties Memphis and Nashville Metro
essentially and there's an implicit
logic there in the votes that well it's
okay for these two urban centers as long
as we pull the rest of the the state off
the eligibility map and I'm trying to
understand where that logic makes the
bill easier to pass well it makes it
easier the pass if you've got folks say
not in my
yard and not in my school system and
those that have and there are some
wonderful school systems in the state of
Tennessee all over the state of
Tennessee but that's all of us put our
money in the pipe all over the state of
Tennessee to take care of the state's
best interest that's all of the state
from Memphis to mountain city and until
we in the state of Tennessee hear again
and all over the country until we start
looking at this holistically if one
child fails we all fail and and until
that happens then we're going to
continue to say not at my backyard that
gets willed down and whittled down and
whittled down into its two major areas
and here again the insulting part of
that is if it it's always with certain
demographics you know poor people black
people Hispanic people folks who have
various issues in life didn't just drop
down from Mars they've been here all
alone so we've got to continue to look
at our own deficiencies as legislators
and those who govern to realize that the
problems that exist were not created by
the people they were created by us the
public education we created it we've got
to recreate it and that's where our mind
has got to be Peter's I want to give you
a chance on on the targeting question
but first I want to just tell the
audience that in just a couple of
minutes here we'll take questions so
prepare for those as far as as targeting
eligibility how's that been in
Pennsylvania and what might you advise
other states you know it's a it's a
great question for public policymakers
but I I myself think it should be as
expansive and as broad as it can be
ideally our educational improvement tax
credit scholarship we focused on
increasing that because it's it's
available across the state in rural
suburban and urban areas all areas and
guess what there's a desire or want in
communities all across the state I've
seen it in in
Orthodox Jewish schools in in the city
of Philadelphia and the city of
Pittsburgh but I've seen it in more
rural Catholic and Christian schools and
I've seen it in in suburban schools that
are you know just private non
denominational schools there are
administrators and in educators in each
of those types of schools that make use
of and benefit for for the families and
the kids educational improvement tax
credit scholarships the one restraint
that we have but that we have twice now
increased is income limits because I
think that who might take advantage of
these are also middle income families
and in low-income families too two
working parents sometimes would love to
make use you know would love to send
their their child to a local Catholic
Christian Jewish and on denominational
school they would like to do that but at
twelve thousand which is not you know
that's a typically price high school
many others go much higher
you know the EITC is is what they need
to get over the goal line and and and it
should be available to as many people as
possible if I could I would increase the
income limits even higher I can't do it
singularly yet give me two legislative
bodies and a governor on board but I
think that's crucial but we have
increased our limits I do think however
that on this what we're doing with a
more robust direct scholarship in
Harrisburg is modeled similarly on what
has happened in Cleveland and in
Milwaukee and I think what the good
representative and his folks are doing
down in Tennessee with respected
Nashville and Memphis at a certain point
I used this phrase already but I'm gonna
repeat it you need to get a foot in the
door and you need to save lives and you
want to do it any way that you can also
I just want to re-emphasize this point
that the treasurer made look
Pennsylvania's the state that spends a
considerable amount of tax dollars on
public education for a lot of students
they get a great education in the public
schools if that's what fits those
particular students that's great but we
know from fact from stories from
encountering families it's it's not one
size fits all and and that choice should
be available and that's what this United
States Secretary of Education and her
team we're proposing let's let's go from
what's happened in the states and take
it across the United States all right
I'd like to turn it open to questions
from the audience if we can again we
have sort of two rules here at AEI when
you have a question just give us your
name and affiliation and then ask a
question Rjay right here - good morning
my name is Mary Lou and I am a science
teacher 33 years in the public school
system in New York I don't hear the
voice of the teacher in any of these
discussions and I feel that they are
large stakeholder how can I return to my
colleagues and assure them that this
educational freedom scholarship will not
harm education as we know it will not
cause them their jobs will not somehow
adversely impact them if we could get
teachers on the side of the scholarships
I think they could influence their
leaders in this direction for that in
first of all I'm the daughter of a
public school teacher who taught for 38
years and in one of the poorest school
districts in the state of Arizona so I I
bring a great respect and admiration to
our public school system when we talk
about these types of school debates and
school reform and I have been one to
always bring those around the table
whether they agree with each other or
not
because the voices are very important to
the end result of
what we will pursue and in this it makes
the case that we will have more
opportunities because the funding is
coming alongside the from the federal
government and it's interesting because
having been in public policy prior to
elective office for 23 years I have
never seen a federal Department of
Education come alongside to partner with
the states and say we're going to take a
hands-off approach on this initiative
and give the states the ability to
design education freedom scholarship how
it works for your state and it's going
to look different from every state in
the country that's great what a
wonderful opportunity and for the public
school advocates in my state I would say
to them that this allows us to counter
the debate that our general fund will
have money scooped away from the public
school system that will not be the case
if we have a supplemental amount of
funding coming from the federal
government for the first time that I can
remember on a school choice design
program so this is an exciting
opportunity that we should be embracing
and I would say that this is a wonderful
opportunity to bring the education
advocates from the public school system
to the table because there's nothing
that says they can't be a part of this
design in Arizona as I shared earlier we
provided a tax credit for public schools
at the same time that we advanced our
school tuition organizations and allowed
for tax credits for individuals and
corporations to move forward funding for
individuals to go to a private school so
everybody got a little bit of something
representatives of everyone to get join
quickly just this morning I hope the
secretary doesn't mind me mentioning it
that we had a conversation about that
very thing and that is letting the
teachers know that they're part of this
there are stakeholders in this and that
it can't be done without them when we
were discussing this in the state of
Tennessee we had kind of a saying that
is sort of like you know you say if
Mama's not happy nobody's happy well if
the teachers are not happy nobody's
happy and I think that all of us have
got to
that to heart and make sure that the
teachers know that if this is going to
succeed or anything we're doing in
education is going to succeed
the teachers are an integral part of it
another another much one less oh I think
this point just has to get made look on
the son of a public school teacher - my
dad was a long time public school
teacher my brother is a public school
teacher but it is true that this
discussion is about the the child that
is where the discussion is and it's
about the parents or the grandparents in
the garden look in Philadelphia there's
200,000 students about 70,000 are in
charge schools about 30,000 more wannabe
in charter schools they have a lottery
my colleague said that the one of the
most frequently asked questions she gets
from her constituents in Philadelphia's
is hey can you help me like get into one
of these charter schools I didn't create
that waiting list of 30,000 families um
70,000 families that already are in
there I didn't create that people are
making a decision family by family that
that they want that opportunity and they
see something maybe it's the uniforms
maybe it's some discipline it's not
always additional laboratories by the
way sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
people want to give their kids a break
that they might not have had in their
lives that's that's what's driving this
that does not mean that the public
school system is gonna disappear I
actually think many public schools will
even get better based on the competition
and I think teachers rise to that level
of competition because the teachers I
know that's what they do the good
teachers that's what they do
thanks that was a great question Brennan
hi I'm Olivia Sullivan and I'm a
freshman at NYU as well as a research
associate at the Federalist Society
and I really appreciate on the panel and
all of your conversation about autonomy
and freedom within education but I do
want to push back on sort of an
assumption
ice I observed that all parents
necessarily have their children's best
interests at heart and how do you ensure
that parents who don't necessarily know
their their children's best interest or
for children who don't have parents who
are in the in the foster system perhaps
how do you make sure that no children
get left behind and that all children
are being advocated for yet the key
there is is you want to save every life
that you can possibly save that's first
and foremost so you got to keep that in
mind and you're right not every child
has that person who's responsible their
life but many do because built into your
statement is an assumption that because
somebody might be of lower economic
value that they don't have the same care
and concern for that child that people
of a higher economic value do and I
think that is innately discriminatory in
addition I will tell you this I've been
with a lot of those parents who are
waiting in line or grandparents or aunts
or uncle's or guardians who want to get
that kid into a charter school I've been
there on that lot every day and let me
tell you those people in fact care very
deeply just recently on the EITC front I
was at a Catholic faire for their school
trying to raise some money a grandma
came up to me and told me you know my
daughter is a drug addict I've taken
charge of this young boy I'm 70 and I'm
so worried about what's gonna happen to
him but I'm hoping that this EITC
scholarship is around because I know
he's gonna get an opportunity that he
would not have otherwise had yeah when I
listen to the young young lady's
question I I hear something else in
there also and and and the the bitter
pill that none of us seem to want to
swallow today in this society is the
fact that the breakdown of the family
and the fact that there are a lot of
children who have no one or at least
don't have the type of family that many
of us have and and these are the
children that are in many places
suffering and these are also the
children that in many places the state
has them as awards and taking care of
them and feeding them and it
hating them and everything else I think
that we've got to put that on the table
when we have this discussion we've got
to talk about the breakdown of the
family the fact that many children don't
have parents who have their best
interests at heart and when as we broker
these various programs and policies that
has got to be on the table
it must be part of the discussion and it
must be solved I'm afraid that we are
out of time so we'll have to let
representative to Barry stand on that
I'd like to thank Speaker tar-zhay
representative to Barry and treasurer
Yee for talking to us today and thank
you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]